what's going on that we have to like we
have to actually feel it why is that the
magic sauce that is the magic sauce so
there's a big difference between
thinking something and feeling something
a huge difference the heart is the
connection to your soul your heart tells
you why your soul came here what it
wanted to express so your heart is
connected to your to the other realm to
your soul your head is connected to this
Physical Realm your head is where you
need to store the tools to help you
navigate on how to get from A to B but
your heart is the one with the vision
because your soul came here with an
intention of something to fulfill I like
to use the term calling because it's
almost like your future self calling you
towards it yeah and yet we always have
the choice as to whether to follow that
or not